he is Andrew Miller the Indians pitcher
been in Major League Baseball for 10
years and was the MVP of the ALCS
although I got it start out well let me
how much celebrating did you do Andrew
first of all congratulations how much
celebrating did you guys do you know I
think we had a good time I think
everybody is looking forward to one more
champagne kind of it hurts a little bit
the next day it's things when you're
doing it the next day we're not used to
drinking that much of it that fast but I
think at the same time as we saved up a
little energy to the next one now do you
believe that you have to wear goggles or
should you just let your body absorb the
champagne ideal you get to the goggles i
didn't get to them this time so like I
said it stings it's not a lot of fun and
I think it's it's fun for people that
are trying to spray it knives and I
think it's part of the experience in a
sense you wouldn't trade that for
anything the nickname the circumstance
is that catching on I don't know I hope
not it's kind of an odd one but I think
you know the the Twitter account for the
Indians and some of the riders whatnot I
sure had a lot of fun with that you know
I'm just glad we were able to go out
there and back it up with circumstance
it what was your do you have another
nickname not really you know you here
Miller time or you know or something
along those lines quite a bit but you
know certainly not the circumstance
that's a new one um trying to think
nothing really is stuck in the past how
about the mild thing where you just kind
of a calm guy who comes in and takes
care of his business instead of the wild
thing I think that sits in Cleveland a
little bit but i don't know maybe Kluber
has that one down I think he's one that
says even killed as anybody we ever seen
or maybe the America it through force
the other day but you know what
nicknames don't really matter i think if
we win at the end of the day I think we
didn't cost whatever you want now how
much do you know about Ryan merit
honestly not much he was around
basically as a sep tember call up and
you know I heard a lot of guys talk
about their played with him in the minor
leagues and he'd been up a little bit
earlier here before I got over here but
you know just what an incredible story
and you know for a guy like that to come
out and show no fear and go out there
and just execute and you know the other
team
trash in the paper and everything it was
pretty impressive feat you know I think
it was a you know it's pretty awesome
we're gonna look back on it and you know
my Marisa guy that won the game is sent
us to the World Series how did you get
the news that you had been traded to the
Indians Brian Cashman called me by eight
o'clock in the morning I was we were
actually playing Tampa which is where I
lives has a chance to you know kind of
sleep in my own bed and enjoy home a
little bit my phone was ringing and I
kind of gotta love sex is a little bit
too early I didn't think I'd set my
alarm that I looked at it and the caller
ID said Brian Cashman oh no no no the
date I knew something was up i do it was
a possibility but you know that's the
reality of the game a very few guys get
the luxury of a no-trade clause or any
sort of leverage in these situations and
you know I didn't have any so that's
just the way it goes would you have use
that no trade clothes you know what it's
a tough thing to say I think you're fine
you yeah I mean you want to stay with
the Yankees I think yeah I love my
teammates there was certainly a comfort
level at how I signed with Yankees to be
part of that team for a lot of reasons
and you know a big one was the fact that
United spring training at all the Tampa
I had you know three times a year we get
to go play there and i really like i
said i love my teammates I think that
team you know had a lot of promise and
it was fun to play there I like the city
but you know what it's hard to say i
think you know things happen for a
reason I'm going to the World Series
because I got traded so in a sense you
know if I about that I've absolutely
adore you know no circumstances job
didn't I think everybody in baseball
jersey they could to sign up for a World
Series he's an Andrew Miller the
circumstance the Indians pitcher joining
a Stan Patrick show did you used to have
a mullet I don't know about a mullet I
had long hair for a little while I think
right now just tom was kind of cornered
the market on mullets for us but uh I
had long hair and I had the big beard
but it was never there was ever business
in the front party all around who has
the worst hair on your team I don't know
it's gonna be hard not to say tomlin
right now I think he but I think he's on
in there pretty well I think he likes it
I don't think he realizes that you know
it looks pretty funny but I don't know
it's hard to top a legitimate moment
saw where of people have brought up the
name Charlie Sheen who of course played
the wild thing in the movie major-league
based on the Cleveland Indians maybe
threw out the first pitch where do you
stand on Charlie Sheen coming in um
honestly haven't heard his name a while
but I think it'd be great i think you
know that's a it's an awesome movie and
you know i think the fans will get a
huge reaction out of that we've had some
pretty neat experiences particularly you
know LeBron has to do is show up and
it'll be the loudest ovation you know
that the stadium will get into but I
think it'd be it'd be pretty fun to
watch get him out there in the Jersey
the 99 and you have the glasses the
skull and crossbones why not the problem
is Charlie may not leave the mail no
Andrew hey that'd be fun to watch too we
had a stricter in Toronto stuff yeah
things that happen like that they don't
seem to faze us and it'd be a lot of fun
have you ever had anybody run onto the
field and you know you get nervous about
it or were you aware of this drinker in
Toronto I was actually inside the
clubhouse Cody Allen was pitching and
you know the ninth inning is I was the
way to get three outs go to the World
Series you know poor Cody's out there
trying to you know calm himself down and
some guys trying to pull his pants down
in right field but not while I've been
on the mound I've seen it quite a bit I
think it's you know they've done a
pretty good job of stays of that I think
once word gets out that you know it's
going to cost you I don't know a couple
grand or something to get out of jail
and hire lawyers it you know most people
tend to shy away from making that move
your favorite Terry Francona story I
don't know it's hard to top the fact
that you know we're pulling our pitcher
and the start standing or whatever
because he's bleeding him in a nap later
looking at the 50-50 in Toronto I think
that he's just so was as always don't
send you know he's his ability to he
kind of talks trash i think you know i
got a chance to have him in boston
watching him to UK with petroi is about
as good as it gets as well but you know
the fact that we're playing ALCS games
and trying to finally hit the world
series of him and Napoli are trying to
figure out how to buy tickets if he
could be creepy how much was the 50-50
where somebody gets fifty fifty percent
and then the house gets fifty percent
what was adopted I think I don't know
what the highest was but I know it got
into six figures for the take-home it
you know I think for probably all three
games we were there so
that I i I've never been anywhere else
like that I think to 5050 in Cleveland
it's a big day if it gets up to six or
ten thousand bucks and that might even
be the whole pocket in Toronto i think
the winners were taken home over a
hundred grand house bowers finger look
disgusting but i think hopefully he'll
not pretty well and they're doing
everything they can as you can imagine
to get it back and you know we need them
we'd like to have him pitches he's a
really good picture I think he's he's an
interesting character and we love him
for that but you know most importantly
we wanted to pitch did he consider
cutting off his pinky I think he would
generally considered uh you know using
some sort of a torch to kind of seal it
up and I think that it's a good thing he
did but I said one more verse but oh my
god I don't know I hey he's in like I
said he's a smart guy but he he's a
competitor to I think he he wouldn't
pitch the other day I think they just
made him come out of the game you know
he's not scared he's not afraid he wants
to be out there which is you know that's
what we want it's been a great story
becoming an overnight success after 10
years in the majors Andrew but you've
done it you were great in the ALCS
getting the MVP where you going to put
that MVP I have no idea to meet trophy I
don't you know at the same time I don't
deserve that I think it's unfair to
single anybody out we've got such a
great team you know some some of the
plays and you know some of the
contributions we have other guys were
you know what got us to where we're at
and you know it'll be neat i'll look
back on it it's one of those things
it'll be fun to have on your mantel but
no more importantly if you nice to get a
World Series ring well good luck in Game
one when that starts you're going to be
watching games Game six of the NLCS yeah
no doubt i think i got some still
playing we want to know where we're
going and maybe do a little bit of
scouting but you know it's a at this
point we're certainly interested in
what's going on yeah i'll watch the
games well congrats and good luck thank
you Andrew of course thank Dan that's
Andrew Miller the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you